Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Afrique, France.
Faut-il évacuer nos bases
militaires en Afrique ?
Beaucoup de pays africains,
qui aujourd'hui cultivent
un sentiment antifrançais,
se sont éloignés
de l'ancien pays colonisateur,
comme on dit, à travers
un putsch militaire. C'est notamment
le cas du Mali, du Burkina Faso,
du Niger. Le cas
du Gabon est un peu spécial,
parce qu'il a changé de régime
par la voie putschiste,
mais sans sentiment
ou sans vindicte antifrançaise.
Les putschs en Afrique sont
d'une banalité reproductive.
Il y en eut plus de 200
depuis les indépendances africaines
intervenues dans les années 60.
Reste cette énigme ou plutôt
ce retournement de paradigme
qui voit se substituer
à la défunte Françafrique
une anti-France populiste,
pleine de ressentiments vis-à-vis
de l'ancien pays colonisateur
et cherchant à se débarrasser
de toute présence militaire
tricolore
pourtant appelée à la rescousse
pour combattre
le terrorisme djihadiste.
D'où vient
et pourquoi cette attitude
antifrançaise,
qui peut faire tache d'huile
et contagion dans les pays africains
abritant encore
des bases militaires françaises,
à savoir la Côte d'Ivoire,
le Sénégal,
le Gabon, Djibouti, le Tchad ?
D'où notre question du jour :
faut-il évacuer
ces bases militaires ?
Au-delà du ressentiment,
nous chercherons à évoquer
avec les questions stratégiques,
n'oublions pas que l'Afrique
est un carrefour convoité
par de nombreux pays
et de nombreuses
puissances émergentes,
évoquer le contexte géoéconomique
lié à une mondialisation
créant de nouveaux rapports
de dépendance et de prédation.
Est-ce que l'Afrique dispose
aujourd'hui des moyens
pour assurer sa sécurité ?
Et aussi de s'interroger
sur une diplomatie française
qui, de la Libye au Maghreb,
s'avère erratique
et bien souvent infructueuse
avec ou sans base militaire.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente mes invités.
Antoine Glaser, vous êtes
journaliste, essayiste,
et vous consacrez
à l'Afrique depuis longtemps.
Niagalé Bagayoko,
vous êtes politologue,
vous enseignez à Sciences Po
et vous avez également
une fondation,
l'African Security Network.
Alors, nos autres invités
sont en visioconférence.
Je présenterai
le général Bruno Clément-Bollée.
Bonjour, général. Vous êtes
ex-directeur de la Coopération
de Sécurité et de Défense
au Quai d'Orsay.
Aminata Dramane Traoré,
nous vous avons, j'allais dire en
visio, mais en vérité par téléphone.
Vous êtes une femme politique
et écrivaine malienne.
Et le colonel
Roger Kuitche, colonel
de réserve dans l'armée camerounaise
et nous vous avons en visio
depuis Yaoundé.
J'allais dire, question d'ambiance,
Antoine Glaser,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui de l'implantation
et du développement
du terrorisme en Afrique ?
-Je sais pas ce qu'on peut dire
du terrorisme en Afrique.
A l'évidence, même les bases
militaires françaises
ou la présence militaire française,
il faut quand même se rappeler
que la France est la seule puissance
extérieure au continent
à avoir des bases permanentes
encore en Afrique,
à l'exception de Djibouti, où là,
il y a le monde entier, les Chinois,
les Américains...
-Les Américains
ne sont pas partout ?
-Tournés vers l'Indopacifique.
En ce qui concerne
le continent africain,
la France est la seule puissance
à avoir encore
des bases permanentes.
Et c'est vrai que les Africains
reprochent à la France de pas avoir
soldé cette période postcoloniale,
des indépendances de 1960
jusqu'à la fin, 1989,
1990,
la fin de l'Union Soviétique,
de l'empire soviétique
sur ce continent.
Comme la France n'a pas soldé,
finalement,
cette présence
de l'armée française a servi
de cache-misère
à une présence française
qui était globalement en déshérence.
Ces militaires, ces bases militaires
ont laissé croire
que la France était
chez elle en Afrique,
que c'était encore elle
qui drivait le continent,
alors que l'Afrique est
totalement mondialisée.
Là, il y a une espèce de hiatus,
et c'est vrai que les bases,
la question du maintien
des bases pose la question
des relations entre la France
et l'Afrique, puisque
ils étaient hors sol
par rapport aux réalités du terrain.
-Alors,
sur cette question du terrorisme,
Mme Niagalé Bagayoko,
quelle est votre perception
de ce qu'il en est
du terrorisme en Afrique ?
On parlera des autres sujets
après, mais sur le terrorisme.
-Alors, tout d'abord,
il faut s'interroger
sur ce que l'on place
sous ce vocable de terrorisme,
puisqu'il ne faut pas oublier
qu'on a affaire
à des mouvances extrêmement
diversifiées qui ont eu tendance
à être trop souvent
réduites les uns aux autres,
alors qu'il y a
des affrontements entre elles.
C'est très important
de mettre cet élément
en avant, notamment
si l'on prend le cas du Sahel,
vous avez une opposition
entre les groupes
affiliés à l'Etat islamique
et les groupes affiliés
à al-Qaïda, qui se combattent
les uns et les autres.
Cette variable est fondamentale.
Mais par ailleurs, on s'aperçoit
qu'on a beaucoup trop réduit
à cette lutte contre
ces groupes armés terroristes,
dits GAT,
les difficultés sécuritaires
expérimentées par le continent,
alors que l'on assiste également
à l'émergence
de milices d'autodéfense
de groupes communautarisés
qui s'affrontent,
de rébellions politico-militaires,
certaines indépendantistes,
d'autres non, au regard bien sûr
du prétorianisme sur le continent.
Donc c'est cet ensemble d'éléments
qu'il faut prendre en considération
pour lutter contre ces insurrections
qui ont une composante djihadiste,
mais dont certains groupes
se présentent au contraire
comme combattant avant tout
les Etats, jugés corrompus
et partenaires
de l'Occident, et se posent
en protecteurs des populations.
La problématique n'est pas
aussi simple. On voit très bien
que la guerre contre le terrorisme
a été perdue
absolument partout,
qu'il s'agisse de l'Afghanistan,
du Moyen-Orient, elle a également
été perdue au Sahel,
car ce vocable
est trop simpliste.
-On vous a entendue là-dessus.
Colonel Roger Kuitche,
quelle est votre analyse
de la présence et de la prégnance
du terrorisme aujourd'hui
dans le continent africain
et plus spécialement peut-être
dans le Sahel ?
*-Une précision
avant de répondre à votre question,
je ne suis pas colonel à la réserve,
mais à la retraite.
J'ai épuisé ma période de réserve.
Je suis dégagé
de toutes les obligations
militaires. Je suis à la retraite.
Ceci dit,
poser le problème du terrorisme
en Afrique dans le cadre
de cette émission, dont le titre,
dont l'objet phare, c'est
les bases militaires en Afrique,
c'est vouloir lier la présence
des bases militaires françaises
en Afrique au terrorisme.
-Contre le terrorisme,
elles sont là pour ça.
-Elles sont là pour ça,
mais d'où vient le terrorisme ?
S'il faut reculer dans le temps...
Propos indistincts
Le terrorisme, il est arrivé
quand en Afrique ?
Les troupes françaises
étaient en Afrique
longtemps
avant l'arrivée du terrorisme.
Alors, si elles étaient là
avant l'arrivée du terrorisme,
elles y étaient pour quoi ?
Le terrorisme en Afrique
aujourd'hui,
pour revenir à votre question,
il est prégnant,
mais depuis quelque temps,
je crois que les Etats africains
se donnent les moyens de faire face
à cette pandémie.
A cette hydre.
L'Afrique aujourd'hui a juste besoin
de pas grand-chose
pour venir à bout du terrorisme
partout où il se trouve.
C'est ce que nous pensons.
-Est-ce que vous pensez
que le terrorisme est contagieux
jusqu'à l'intérieur des Etats ?
-Il faut savoir que le terrorisme
est au départ une doctrine.
C'est au départ une doctrine
et on ne tue pas une doctrine.
C'est des idées qui circulent.
Des idées qui circulent sur la base
de certaines revendications
faites aux autorités
et qui entraînent
parfois la radicalisation
de certaines parties
prenantes.
Ce n'est que des individus
qui peuvent diffuser leurs idées
à travers les frontières
pour le terrorisme,
mais n'oubliez pas
que le terrorisme originel
n'existe pratiquement...
pas qu'il n'existe pas,
mais les bandits de grand chemin
prennent pour manteau
le terrorisme pour agir.
Oui, des idées peuvent circuler
d'un pays à l'autre,
mais l'impact et la signification
tant que les idées djihadistes
et autres ne sont pas
assimilées vont connaître
des limites.
-Alors,
général Clément-Bollée,
on vous retrouve là. Est-ce que
les bases militaires françaises
anciennes et présentes
étaient là et sont là
pour lutter contre le terrorisme ?
Puisque nous sommes
à ce niveau de la conversation.
*-Oui, alors peut-être un petit mot
pour revenir sur le terme
de terrorisme, parce qu'on le dévoie
beaucoup en ce moment,
un petit peu partout,
compte tenu de l'ampleur
des événements qui y sont liés.
Le terrorisme, je rappelle
que c'est un mode d'action.
Le terrorisme dont nous parlons
en Afrique actuellement,
ce sont des religieux extrémistes
qui ont pris pour mode d'action
pour faire valoir leur extrémisme
le principe du terrorisme.
Le terrorisme, donc inspirer
la terreur auprès des populations.
Les bases françaises
en Afrique actuellement,
il y a 6000 militaires français
en Afrique, répartis sur 4 bases.
C'est les bases qu'on connaissait
hier et qui ont été revisitées
et très fortement dégraissées,
les effectifs ont été
très fortement diminués
ces dernières années.
Il nous reste donc le Sénégal, la
Côte d'Ivoire, le Gabon et Djibouti.
Ce total fait
à peu près 3000 soldats.
Et il faut rajouter à ça
les éléments français du Sahel,
qui sont répartis entre le Niger,
de moins en moins,
et le Tchad,
qui sont à peu près 2500.
Il faudrait rajouter
la petite mission Corymbe,
la mission maritime
dans le golfe de Guinée
avec 500 personnes à peu près,
et puis, en fond de tableau,
on a aussi le dispositif
de coopération militaire,
qui n'est pas
très important quantitativement,
mais qui, qualitativement,
de par la position
qu'ont tous ces coopérants
dans les systèmes sécuritaires
en Afrique,
représente un dispositif
qu'il ne faut pas négliger.
Voilà. Et donc,
ces bases françaises,
si vous voulez, participent-elles
au terrorisme ? Oui,
dans la mesure où elles coopèrent
avec les Etats dans lesquels
elles sont installées,
donc par ce biais-là,
elles coopèrent.
Mais ce n'est pas aujourd'hui
de la coopération
du type de celle qu'on a vécue
au travers de Barkhane.
Mais peut-être un mot
sur à quoi servent-elles,
ces bases françaises ?
-On va y venir, général.
On va y venir. Je voudrais
avoir l'avis de Mme Aminata Traoré
là-dessus, sur la persistance
du terrorisme en Afrique.
A quoi vous l'attribuez ?
Je rappelle
qu'on vous a par téléphone.
*-Oui, je commence par dire
que c'est un mot impasse,
fourre-tout.
Le débat fait rage
à ce sujet en ce moment
en France à la faveur du conflit
israélo-palestinien.
Je crois que
la même perspicacité
devrait s'imposer dans l'analyse
de ce dont il s'agit en Afrique.
Parce que, moi, ce que je sais,
si je me réfère aux réalités
de mon pays, le Mali,
en son nom,
la France est revenue
avec armes et bagages
à imposer son narratif,
sa stratégie,
elle a échoué.
C'est ce qui a amené
le peuple malien qui avait accueilli
l'opération Serval
avec enthousiasme
a demandé le départ
et de Barkhane et de la MINUSMA.
Donc cela doit être clair.
Et dès les années 60,
le président Modibo Keïta a demandé
le départ de l'armée française,
le dernier soldat français parti.
La réalité du Mali, les autres
pays qui sont aujourd'hui,
qui abritent des bases militaires,
c'est pas le cas du Mali.
Donc l'intervention militaire
de la France au Mali
au nom d'un phénomène
qu'on appelle le terrorisme
lui a valu ce que vous appelez
sentiment antifrançais.
C'est pas lié aux coups d'Etat.
C'est antérieur.
C'est lié d'abord à l'échec
de ce type d'intervention militaire
dans le cadre de la lutte
contre un phénomène
qu'on appelle
le terrorisme islamiste.
-Oui, mais Mme Traoré,
je voudrais quand même
qu'on éclaircisse quelque chose.
Vous avez évoqué le Moyen-Orient.
La position française, c'est que le
Hamas est un groupe terroriste
et en même temps, il y a un soutien
pour la création de deux Etats
et au peuple palestinien.
Est-ce que vous considérez
qu'en Afrique,
le califat et tout ce qui est venu
comme terrorisme
après, j'allais dire, la disparition
de Kadhafi
a amené en Afrique
un terrorisme de nature islamiste ?
-D'abord, il y a pas de califat.
-Il y avait un califat, avant.
Je vous cite,
notre ministre Lecornu a déclaré
que "la recrudescence du terrorisme
nous laisse craindre
"l'implantation d'un califat
"que nous avons réussi
à entraver et repousser."
Vous êtes pas d'accord
avec cette opinion ?
C'est la position française.
-C'est absolument faux.
C'est le narratif français
qui permet, qui a permis
de fédérer les opinions
à son intervention. Moi, je voudrais
que 10 ans plus tard, vraiment,
qu'on se rende à l'évidence.
Si vous voulez éviter, comme
vous l'avez dit en introduction,
l'expansion à l'échelle du continent
du sentiment antifrançais,
il faut sortir de l'inaudibilité
qui caractérise la France,
qui est le manque total
d'objectivité,
on ne nous écoute pas.
Vous êtes dans l'interprétation.
Mais je vous dis, je regrette,
je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce diagnostic de M. Lecornu.
Nous sommes dans une impasse liée
au fait que les solutions
ne sont pas en face
des maux dont souffre l'Afrique.
-Merci.
Antoine Glaser sur ce point,
parce qu'il semblerait
qu'il y ait pas d'accord.
-Non, mais il fallait
à un certain moment donné
que la France justifie
sa présence militaire
vis-à-vis finalement
des citoyens français
en disant,
attention, le terrorisme, va
venir de cette zone
sahélo-saharienne.
C'est complètement faux.
On n'a jamais vu un Malien
faire un acte terroriste en France.
Ca a toujours été
beaucoup plus nos banlieues.
Qu'il y ait des citoyens français
qui soient allés
au Proche, Moyen-Orient, c'est
différent. Mais il y a un amalgame
incroyable dans cette zone
sahélo-saharienne
entre ce qui a été dit
par le général Clément-Bollée,
entre les coupeurs de route
ou les trafics
en tous genres. Cette zone, c'est
une très grande zone de trafics
en tous genres,
la drogue, le trafic humain, etc.
Un certain nombre de jeunes,
bien sûr, ont été pris en main
par des groupes islamistes,
parce qu'ils cherchaient simplement
du travail.
Il y a pas de califat ni quoi
que ce soit. Et il y a une chose
dont personne ne parle,
c'est une période historique
qui se termine.
-L'intervention de la France
à l'époque de la présidence Hollande
au Mali s'est faite
pour combattre le terrorisme.
-C'est pour empêcher
un petit groupe,
un certain nombre
effectivement de djihadistes,
dont la France avait
une responsabilité avec l'assassinat
du colonel Kadhafi,
qui sont rentrés de Libye,
des Touaregs
qui étaient des indépendantistes
qui se sont alliés avec des gens
d'al-Qaïda du Maghreb islamique,
ce qui a donné le Groupe du soutien
à l'islam et aux musulmans.
Ils seraient descendus,
ils seraient pas arrivés à Bamako,
La France, Serval, serait partie,
il y aurait eu aucun problème.
Les gens ne connaissent pas.
Ils se rendent pas compte
qu'il y a une islamisation.
Il faut pas confondre
le terrorisme avec l'islamisation
depuis la Mauritanie
jusqu'au Soudan,
mais avec des wahhabites,
avec du prosélytisme saoudien,
qatari, des Emiratis.
-Et sans imprégnation
terroriste ?
-Bien sûr qu'il y a
des noyaux terroristes,
mais c'est pas l'essentiel.
C'est la période postcoloniale,
on rentre dans une nouvelle
période historique,
c'est l'Afrique des Africains,
mais il y a une diversité,
même entre eux. Et je vais dire,
c'est vrai, tu as raison,
quand tu dis
que, par exemple,
al-Qaïda du Maghreb islamique,
ils se battent avec l'Etat islamique
au Grand Sahara. Il y a aussi
un certain nombre...
Ils se combattent entre eux.
La situation est très complexe
et il faut comprendre
que c'est une période historique.
Général
Clément-Bollée,
comment vous défendez
les interventions françaises
si elles n'étaient pas là
pour lutter
contre le terrorisme ?
-Alors, peut-être,
au risque de vous surprendre,
je crois qu'au départ
de cette affaire, donc 2012, 2013,
il me semble, pour ma part,
qu'il y a peut-être eu
une erreur d'analyse
et qu'on a confondu les causes
et les conséquences.
Globalement,
je suis parfaitement en phase
avec ce que vient de dire
Antoine Glaser.
J'ai peur qu'on ait fait
du terrorisme,
qui commençait
à descendre vers Bamako,
l'unique cause de la déstabilisation
de toute cette région.
Mais je pense
que ça n'était pas la cause.
Ca n'était qu'une conséquence.
La conséquence de ce que vient
d'expliquer Antoine Glaser.
D'une zone complètement laissée
à l'abandon,
une absence d'Etat quasi totale,
où l'Etat ne remplit plus
ses missions régaliennes
d'éducation des jeunes,
de santé des populations,
de résolution des problèmes sociaux.
Et donc dans ce magma
et dans cette anarchie globale,
le terrorisme qui descendait
avait beau jeu de faire son lit.
Et... Et j'ai peur
que l'analyse qu'on en ait faite
se soit concentrée quasi uniquement
sur cette affaire de terrorisme,
oubliant le reste.
Et donc la réponse que nous avons
donnée pendant des années,
jusqu'à 2021, 2022,
était quasiment que sécuritaire,
au détriment d'une vision globale
qui nous aurait permis d'apporter
des réponses outre sécuritaires,
mais des réponses
politiques, économiques, sociales,
et c'est tout ça qui a manqué.
Je crois que... Je mets pas du tout
en faute les militaires,
qui ont, à mon sens, très bien fait
techniquement
ce qu'on leur demandait,
je remets en cause
l'analyse
au départ de notre engagement
qui a fait que...
on a fait du problème du terrorisme
l'unique cause
de ce qu'il fallait défendre.
Et donc,
quand vous avez qu'une cause,
vous donnez des réponses à la cause.
La seule réponse
que nous avons donnée,
puisque notre analyse était courte,
a été sécuritaire.
-Niagalé Bagayoko,
sur ce point-là ?
-Ce que je trouve
intéressant dans cette discussion,
c'est que nous sommes 5 intervenants
qui ont une convergence
absolue dans leurs analyses.
C'est-à-dire qu'on ne nie pas qu'il
y a des actes de nature terroriste
dans cette zone, bien entendu,
mais d'abord, les actes
qui sont commis n'ont rien à voir
avec le terrorisme
tel qu'on l'a expérimenté en Europe.
Il y a eu très peu d'attentats
ciblant des civils dans les villes
notamment,
ce sont plutôt les populations
qui sont les premières victimes
de ces différents groupes
djihadistes.
C'est la 1re chose.
On ne va nier non plus
que l'emprise de ces insurrections
djihadistes s'étend maintenant
au-delà du Sahel
pour toucher notamment
les pays côtiers,
voire certaines zones
de l'Afrique centrale et de l'est.
Ce que l'on souligne tous, je pense,
c'est qu'on ne peut pas considérer
que le mot de terrorisme
suffit à résumer
la réalité sécuritaire
de cette zone,
c'est le premier élément,
et d'autre part,
la présence militaire française
est bien antérieure,
comme l'a dit le colonel
tout à l'heure,
à cette problématique
dite terroriste
et a donc d'autres...
...d'autres explications.
La question qui se pose aujourd'hui
est de savoir
pourquoi il y a un tel rejet
de la France.
C'est notamment parce que
la France a affirmé être en mesure
d'éradiquer le terrorisme,
alors que la crise
sécuritaire est beaucoup
plus large et excède
non seulement les moyens
de la France,
mais de tous les partenaires
internationaux.
On voit l'échec des Nations unies,
de l'UE, de la Russie
sur le plan sécuritaire,
qui n'inverse pas la situation,
parce qu'une fois de plus,
les manifestations sont
beaucoup plus larges.
Et je pense qu'il est important
que nos dirigeants aussi le prennent
en considération, parce que
l'insécurité ne cesse de progresser,
mais les réponses trop militarisées
notamment ne permettent pas
d'y répondre.
-Mme Aminata Traoré,
vous vouliez intervenir.
Je rappelle
que vous êtes en liaison radio.
-Oui. Je crois
qu'il faut en finir également
avec cette idée selon laquelle
la zone était laissée à l'abandon
par des Etats faibles,
qui ont failli, ainsi de suite.
C'est totalement insuffisant
pour rendre compte
des causes structurelles
du phénomène dont il s'agit,
pour rendre compte
de la lame de fond qui fait
que ce dont il s'agit,
appelons-le terrorisme
pour l'instant,
se répand. On donne l'impression
en ce moment
aux Etats côtiers
et au reste de l'Afrique,
que circonscrire le mal au Sahel
le mettra à l'abri justement
de tout ce que nous déplorons
aujourd'hui. Il s'agit pas
de l'abandon...
Il ne s'agit pas
que de l'incapacité de ces Etats.
Ce sont des Etats.
Si nous occultons le contexte
dans lequel ce phénomène a surgi,
et parallèlement
au phénomène migratoire,
je parle de la migration
comme elle se déroule en ce moment,
c'est lié à l'échec lamentable
du modèle économique
mis en oeuvre dans ces pays,
leurs programmes d'ajustement
structurels qui ne permettent pas,
qui n'ont pas permis,
et tout ce qui se poursuit
en ce moment,
qui ne permet pas
de créer d'emplois,
de répondre aux besoins existentiels
des gens,
les pousse dans les bras
de ce que vous voulez,
toutes sortes de trafiquants,
ceux qui recrutent ces jeunes-là
pour en faire
des combattants d'une cause
qu'eux-mêmes définissent mal.
Donc il y a énormément
de malentendus
autour de cette affaire-là,
tant qu'on n'aura pas compris
justement à la faveur
du basculement du monde
qui est en cours,
que la France a cruellement
besoin de l'Afrique,
qu'il s'agit pas
du sauvetage du Mali,
du Burkina, du reste du continent.
Il s'agit du sauvetage
de la France elle-même.
-Merci, Madame.
Je vais demander l'avis
du colonel Roger Kuitche là-dessus
et vous me dites, colonel,
dans ce cas, pourquoi avoir
fait venir la milice Wagner ?
Si ça n'est pas pour lutter
contre du terrorisme.
-J'avais d'abord voulu rebondir
sur l'inaudibilité dont a parlé,
je crois, c'est Mme Aminata.
Je pense que ce type d'émission
permet de tirer
des leçons pour améliorer l'avenir.
Et cette inaudibilité
est un véritable problème.
Comment ne peut-on pas se rendre
compte qu'en Afrique aujourd'hui,
on assiste au déploiement
d'un dynamisme plus ou moins affirmé
tendant à la liquidation
des systèmes
coloniaux de prédation ?
Les rébellions idéologiques
et parfois militaires
le montrent suffisamment.
Ne pas le voir, c'est s'exposer
encore aux surprises stratégiques.
Mais les bases militaires,
j'ai essayé de parcourir un peu
les missions
des militaires en Afrique,
la mission, c'est protéger
les ressortissants français
sur le territoire africain
et protéger les intérêts français.
Quid des intérêts du pays hôte ?
C'est dans tous les pays,
que ce soit les éléments français
au Tchad, les éléments Licorne.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils font en Afrique
après tous ces événements ?
Le véritable problème
vient de ce que
il n'y a pas, j'allais dire,
une sorte de deal
pour comprendre exactement quels
sont les besoins et les problèmes
de l'Afrique, des missions
militaires anormalement longues,
sans objectifs précis,
déterminés dans le temps
et mesurables dans le temps.
Alors, si vous posez la question
de savoir pourquoi Wagner,
avant Wagner, l'Afrique existait.
L'Afrique se battait.
Aujourd'hui, si la France
ne veut pas se rendre compte
de la nécessité
de la multipolarité
et d'essayer de se battre,
de se conformer aux réalités,
au monde qui change,
pour accepter la multipolarité
et tous les autres partenaires
qui sont là,
ce serait vraiment difficile
pour tout le monde.
Tout le monde a besoin
de tout le monde pour se bâtir.
Pour venir là-dessus, j'ai dit
les missions françaises en Afrique,
elles sont arrivées,
on les a bien accueillies,
mais elles sont
anormalement longues,
elles n'ont pas
d'agenda bien défini.
J'ai regardé,
il y a environ 5630 militaires
français en Afrique,
mais c'est pour quoi ?
-Oui, mais colonel,
permettez que je vous interrompe,
si on regarde
les échanges économiques
entre l'Afrique
et le reste du monde,
la France est très loin derrière
des pays comme la Chine.
Donc, en matière de prédation,
la France est très, très loin
de cette prédation
qui peut venir de l'Asie.
La question que je vous pose,
c'est est-ce que les forces
qui viennent de Chine,
de Turquie, de Russie,
vous pensez qu'elles sont là
uniquement par philanthropie ?
-Personne
n'est dupe pour penser
qu'il y a de la philanthropie,
les Etats n'ont pas d'amis,
que des intérêts.
La France est restée
longtemps en Afrique,
car elle avait vu son intérêt.
Le véritable problème, ce que
nous constatons avec le recul,
est que la France a très peu pris en
compte les intérêts des Africains.
La France était
inaudible. Je viens de lire
qu'on a publié un rapport
de l'Assemblée nationale
sur les raisons
du sentiment antifrançais.
Je ne dirais pas
un sentiment antifrançais.
La relation avec la France
est un héritage qu'on assume.
Nous parlons le français.
Je dirais un sentiment
antipolitique française.
Nous aimons bien la France, nous
avons beaucoup d'amis en France.
C'est pas un sentiment antifrançais
en tant que tel. Dans ce rapport,
il me paraît qu'on dit
qu'il faut rebâtir les relations
avec la France
à travers une aide
au développement réorientée
et...
une efficacité
de l'aide publique au déploiement
et une offre stratégique
et militaire.
C'est ce que nous attendons
depuis 60 ans.
Très peu d'armées africaines
qui ont évolué avec la France
disposent de matériel français
pour faire face au djihadisme.
-Colonel, le général Clément-Bollée
veut réagir là-dessus.
Général, vous avez entendu
ce qui a été dit, la France
dans sa présence en Afrique
n'a pas défendu
les intérêts africains.
Comment réagissez-vous
quand vous entendez cela ?
-J'ai trouvé les propos
du colonel Kuitche
très intéressants, il a soulevé
des choses et des réalités
qui nous remontent peut-être
un peu à la figure aujourd'hui.
Effectivement, les missions
de la présence militaire française,
c'est d'abord la protection
des intérêts vitaux,
dont les ressortissants,
mais les intérêts économiques
qui sont assez minimes, il faut,
pour ceux qui connaissent la partie,
il faut le reconnaître.
Et enfin, les intérêts de puissance
et c'est ça qui est
extrêmement important.
La France qui se veut une puissance
moyenne à vocation mondiale,
sans l'Afrique,
elle aura du mal à assumer ça.
Et donc, je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le colonel,
la France a besoin d'une relation
particulière avec l'Afrique
et elle doit la soigner
et se faire comprendre
du continent africain.
Et c'est peut-être ça, justement,
sur lequel...
-Le colonel a dit que la France
n'a pas pris en considération
les intérêts africains.
-Oui.
-Que répondez-vous à cela, général ?
-J'y venais,
cher Monsieur, j'y venais.
En fait,
quand nous expliquons aujourd'hui
la présence militaire en Afrique,
on ne se focalise
que sur nos intérêts,
les intérêts que nous défendons
et les raisons
pour lesquelles ils sont là
et jamais quasiment
nous n'expliquons
quels intérêts l'Afrique
peut retirer de cette présence.
Je me rappelle,
au début des années 2000,
j'étais à l'Elysée en charge
des dossiers de sécurité en Afrique.
Nous avons eu exactement
le même problème
sur la situation en Côte d'Ivoire.
En 2002,
quand nous sommes intervenus
pour séparer les rebelles du nord
et les gens du sud,
et les forces armées du sud,
on a été conspués
d'abord en Côte d'Ivoire,
où on nous a demandé
de quoi nous mêlions-nous,
ensuite, ça s'est répandu
dans les journaux
de toutes les capitales africaines
et on était incapables
d'expliquer pourquoi,
quel était l'intérêt
de la présence militaire française
pour l'Afrique, pour les Africains.
C'est un dossier très lourd
que j'ai eu à porter à l'Elysée,
puisque j'étais en charge de la
situation sécuritaire en Afrique.
La réponse que nous avons donnée,
c'est que nous avons couplé
notre présence militaire en Afrique
à la montée en puissance
des forces africaines en attente.
Et on a donné très clairement
comme mission à chacune de nos bases
de se mettre à la disposition
des sous-régions africaines
pour aider à la montée en puissance
de ce qu'on appelle
la force africaine en attente,
l'Union Africaine ayant,
avec les sous-régions, décidé
de faire monter en puissance
une force interafricaine
au niveau de chacune
des sous-régions.
La base du Sénégal se mettait
à la disposition du CDAO,
la base de Djibouti à la disposition
de... pardon...
-De l'IGAD.
-De l'IGAD, oui, pardon.
Merci. Le Gabon à la disposition
de la CEAC.
Et la base de la Réunion,
puisque nous n'avons pas de présence
historique en Afrique australe,
se mettait à la disposition
de la SADC.
J'ai eu à expliquer
ce dispositif
à l'Union Africaine
et à chacune des sous-régions.
Je peux vous dire
que dans les mois qui ont suivi,
tout s'est calmé
parce que nous avions répondu
à l'interrogation africaine :
"Pourquoi êtes-vous présents
aujourd'hui,
"vous, militaires français,
en Afrique ?"
Peut-être que cet effort-là,
il serait bon
de le refaire aujourd'hui
pour que notre présence,
si nous la maintenons,
soit acceptée.
-Merci, général.
Bien, nous allons poursuivre
notre conversation.
Alors, il y a un paradoxe.
Les coups d'Etat en Afrique,
Mali, Burkina Faso, Niger,
ça a été rappelé,
se sont accompagnés
d'un sentiment antifrançais,
alors que la Françafrique,
il faut bien le reconnaître,
aujourd'hui,
est en encéphalogramme plat,
ou a même quasiment disparu.
Est-ce qu'à votre avis,
Niagalé Bagayoko,
ce sentiment antifrançais
est lié
à la présence
des bases militaires ?
-En tout cas,
il s'agit du symbole,
avec le franc CFA,
qui est le plus souvent brandi
aujourd'hui
pour dénoncer une présence
qui est perçue
comme beaucoup trop intrusive
dans les affaires régaliennes
des Etats africains,
mais il y a eu
plusieurs éléments
qui ont amené à ce que...
Je suis d'accord
avec le colonel,
il convient, à mon avis,
davantage de qualifier ceci
de sentiment de rejet
de la politique étrangère
de la France en Afrique
plutôt que de sentiment antifrançais
en tant que tel,
parce que ce sont précisément
tous ces attributs,
perçus comme la survivance
d'un système
qui a démontré son inefficacité,
qui sont remis en cause
aujourd'hui.
On a suffisamment parlé
de la lutte
contre le terrorisme.
Pourquoi y a-t-il rejet
aujourd'hui ?
Parce qu'on estime,
dans les opinions
publiques africaines,
que la France,
malgré les moyens
dont elle affirmait disposer,
s'est révélée tout à fait incapable
de contenir l'expansion
des insurrections djihadistes,
commettant des actes terroristes.
Par ailleurs,
on reproche aussi
à la France
sa collusion
avec un certain nombre de régimes,
qui n'étaient
que des démocraties de façade,
voire son indulgence
envers des régimes
militaires, putschistes,
comme le Tchad,
et sa sévérité
envers d'autres.
C'est le double discours
qu'elle utilise
qui est remis en cause.
Enfin, on lui reproche aussi
la façon dont formellement
elle s'adresse,
par le biais
de ses plus hautes autorités,
aux acteurs africains,
les sociétés civiles
ou les autorités étatiques,
à travers un discours
qui apparaît
beaucoup trop moralisateur
ou paternaliste.
C'est, à mon avis, cela
qui nourrit
le sentiment de rejet
de la politique
actuellement menée
par la France en Afrique.
-Merci.
Alors, colonel Kuitche,
je voudrais avoir
votre avis là-dessus.
Les bases militaires françaises
ne sont plus là
au Mali, au Burkina,
au Niger,
Concernant
la mondialisation économique,
la France est
complètement distancée
par des pays
comme la Chine, la Russie,
la Turquie, etc.
Pourquoi persiste alors
dans ce cas-là
un sentiment antifrançais,
puisque la Françafrique
n'est plus là,
les bases militaires
ne sont plus là ?
On revoit ce qu'a été
la politique française
en Afrique.
Donc, à mon avis,
c'est à l'Afrique de refonder
sa politique sans la France.
On peut pas demander
à continuer avec un pays
avec lequel
on a souhaité rompre
des liens militaires
et amoindrir
les liens économiques.
-Pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a souhaité
rompre ces liens ?
Le général a parlé tout à l'heure
de la réorientation des missions
des bases françaises en Afrique
dans le cadre
de la montée en puissance
des forces en attente.
Désolé, on donne l'impression
qu'il y a une faible volonté
des Français
de puissamment équiper
les armées africaines.
Plus de 60 ans de formation.
Les équipements, aujourd'hui,
dans les armées africaines
dirigées par la France
ou bien formées
par la France
sont encore
des équipements vétustes.
Je peux vous dire que nous,
tous les pays africains,
sommes jaloux
de tout ce qui est donné
à l'Ukraine.
Donnez-nous le tiers
de ce qui a été donné
à l'Ukraine
et nous allons combattre
le terrorisme,
notamment
les moyens aériens.
Donc, si les relations
sont rompues,
les séquelles restent.
Les séquelles restent.
Et puis, cette grosse arnaque
du franc CFA.
-Mais on vit pas
en faisant suppurer
le passé, colonel.
-Non, on ne peut pas avancer
sans tenir compte du passé.
La rupture
n'est pas brutale,
encore que je vous ai dit
que ce n'était pas
un sentiment antifrançais
en tant que tel.
Non, c'est un sentiment
anti-politique française.
Nos relations avec les Français
restent.
Nos relations avec eux restent,
mais il faudrait
les réorienter
dans l'intérêt
des Africains.
Aujourd'hui,
ça doit être du win-win.
Ca doit être du win-win.
Ces bases africaines
dans leur conception initiale
ne nous servent pas
à grand-chose.
Nous ne voyons pas nos intérêts
dans la présence de ces bases.
-Je vous pose la question,
et elle va être posée
à tous nos intervenants :
est-ce que vous êtes favorables
aujourd'hui
à ce que la France évacue
toutes ses bases militaires,
à savoir en Côte d'Ivoire,
au Sénégal, au Gabon,
à Djibouti ?
Puisque la question est posée.
-Dans l'intérêt supérieur...
Quand on fait le bilan
de la présence
de ces forces militaires,
le Mali n'a pas recouvré
l'intégralité de son territoire.
Il hésite.
En RCA, on a toujours
des conflits intercommunautaires.
Donc, le résultat,
il est vraiment marginal.
Dans ces conditions,
moi, je pense
que dans l'intérêt supérieur
de la France,
ces bases doivent être retirées,
et c'est déjà trop tard.
-Toutes ces bases ?
Toutes ces bases, encore que
l'Afrique n'est pas un pays.
L'Afrique n'est pas un pays.
Vous dites "Françafrique".
L'Afrique est un continent
qui a plusieurs pays.
Effectivement,
les bases n'existent pas
dans tous les Etats africains.
Donc, à la fin,
ce sera géré au cas par cas,
en fonction des intérêts
de chaque pays,
mais mon sentiment personnel,
en tant qu'ancien militaire
ayant combattu le terrorisme
dans certains points de l'Afrique,
c'est que le bilan
ne nous permet pas aujourd'hui
d'accepter la présence
des bases françaises
si les missions
ne sont pas réorientées
dans l'intérêt des Africains.
-Vous entendez, Antoine Glaser,
ce que dit le colonel :
il faut évacuer
toutes les bases militaires.
-Il faut... Pardon.
-Quel est votre point de vue ?
-Mon point de vue,
c'est qu'il faut déjà comprendre
pourquoi ces bases étaient là.
Ces bases,
elles étaient là
dans une période historique
très particulière.
On a l'impression
que tout le monde a oublié
ces 30 ans où même
les propres alliés de la France
étaient très contents
que la France soit là
au nom de la lutte
contre l'URSS.
Pendant toute la période
de Guerre froide, en Afrique,
la France assurait finalement...
L'Occident assurait la sécurité
contre l'Union Soviétique,
de 1960 jusqu'à la chute
du mur de Berlin.
Ca a continué jusqu'à la chute
Si on prend pas en compte
cette période historique,
ce système intégré
de la Françafrique,
où la France avait
ses bases militaires...
Du point de vue économique
de la France, elle avait le pétrole,
l'uranium,
les marchés à 50-60 %.
Ses propres alliés,
comme l'Allemagne...
L'Allemagne est devenue
le premier exportateur
de l'Europe vers l'Afrique.
La France avait l'armée
et ce système intégré.
Maintenir des bases permanentes
en Afrique...
Pendant que la France a continué
à faire le gendarme
après cette période,
c'est les autres
qui faisaient le business.
La France n'a pas vu
l'Afrique
se mondialiser.
On parle toujours, bien sûr,
de la Russie, de Wagner,
mais les Turcs
proposent des drones,
les Américains
sont pas partis du Niger
alors que la France
s'est fait virer du Niger.
La France n'est pas seule.
La Françafrique,
c'est une période
historique,
mais maintenant,
c'est terminé.
C'est open bar pour tout le monde.
-On va rester
sur les bases militaires.
Général Clément-Bollée,
vous avez entendu
ce qu'a dit le colonel Kuitche,
ce qu'a dit Antoine Glaser.
Est-ce que la France
doit évacuer
toutes ses bases militaires
en Afrique ?
Je vous poserai
une question
qui est corrélative
à ce point-là :
Est-ce qu'on resterait,
dans ce cas-là,
une grande puissance,
même si on nous considère
aujourd'hui
comme une puissance moyenne ?
J'aimerais avoir votre avis
très clairement
sur ces bases militaires.
*-Oui,
je vais, bien sûr, vous le donner.
Je pense qu'aujourd'hui,
il y a effectivement
ce sentiment antifrançais,
qui se focalise,
comme l'a très bien dit Niagalé,
sur l'image du militaire
parce que c'est
le bouc émissaire facile,
parce que notre dispositif
est très, très visible.
Les drapeaux français
dans les rues d'Abidjan...
Tout ça est très visible.
Le problème
qu'on rencontre aujourd'hui,
c'est que
chaque base militaire française
est un îlot d'exaspération
de la rue africaine.
C'est ça qu'on vit aujourd'hui.
Je suis encore une fois
absolument d'accord
avec l'analyse d'Antoine Glaser,
ces temps ont vécu.
Maintenant,
j'ai l'impression
que dans ce débat,
on fait pas...
"Soit on maintient les bases,
soit on les évacue",
mais il y a peut-être
un dispositif intermédiaire.
Repenser...
Repenser notre façon de gérer
les affaires sécuritaires,
les dossiers sécuritaires français
en Afrique,
repenser la forme de notre présence,
pourquoi s'en priver
et pourquoi ne pas le faire
en corrélation
avec nos partenaires africains
pour cette présence revisitée ?
Je parlais tout à l'heure
d'un dispositif
de coopération militaire.
Peut-être que c'est là-dessus
qu'il faut réorienter
un engagement français ?
Pour répondre clairement
à votre question,
moi, je pense que l'heure
des bases françaises en Afrique
a vécu, est finie.
Maintenir
une base française en Afrique,
c'est se mettre en...
C'est créer un îlot
d'exaspération.
On le voit bien
dans les rues du Sénégal,
dans les rues de Dakar,
dans les rues d'Abidjan.
Regardez ce que pense
l'opinion publique,
lisez les journaux locaux.
Il faudrait pas
que ça se termine comme au Niger.
Je crois que si on anticipe ça,
si on comprend bien ça
et que si on réfléchit
à inscrire
un engagement sécuritaire
pensé en relation
avec nos partenaires africains,
notamment
en y soulignant leurs intérêts...
Inscrire tout ça
dans une nouvelle politique
africaine de la France,
avec sa dimension
de développement,
sa dimension économique,
sa dimension sociale,
aurait tout son sens.
En tout cas,
je suis farouchement opposé
à ce que la France rompe
ses relations
avec l'Afrique.
-On vous a entendu.
Merci, général.
Madame Aminata Traoré,
vous voulez intervenir sur ce point.
Merci aussi de nous donner
votre point de vue
sur la présence ou la fin
de ces bases militaires
en Afrique.
Les bases militaires
françaises.
*-C'est mon tour ?
-Oui, c'est à vous.
*-OK, d'accord.
Je voudrais juste,
par rapport
au sentiment antifrançais,
rappeler que les sanctions
imposées au Mali
par la CEDEAO
ont joué un rôle déterminant
dans la colère de la rue,
non seulement au Mali,
mais aussi dans différents pays,
jusqu'au niveau de la diaspora.
Ca, c'est extrêmement important
en raison de ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui
la "punition collective".
Elle est aujourd'hui infligée
au peuple du Niger,
au nom du retour
à l'ordre constitutionnel.
Maintenant,
pour ce qui est
des bases militaires,
moi, je pense
qu'il faut vraiment être
à l'écoute de toutes ces...
Vous ne pouvez pas vous imaginer
les dynamiques
qui sont en cours ici,
comment et pourquoi
les gens sont sortis.
Alors, quand on pense
que la guerre,
en tout cas,
l'intervention militaire,
elle n'a pas tenu
ses promesses,
dans le cas du Mali,
en tout cas,
et d'autres pays sahéliens,
et qu'il fallait
que la France parte...
C'est là qu'il faut entendre.
Moi, je ne suis pas jalouse
des moyens militaires donnés
à l'Ukraine.
Ici, je crois
que ce qui convient le mieux
à une région du monde
comme l'Afrique,
c'est comme l'Union Africaine
l'a dit,
mais sans pouvoir faire
quoi que ce soit,
c'est faire taire les armes.
Tout comme on plaide aujourd'hui
pour le cessez-le-feu en Palestine,
il faut faire taire les armes
en Ukraine, en Palestine,
au Congo et au Sahel.
Nous avons cruellement besoin
de ce moyen.
La guerre ne profite
qu'aux lobbies de l'armement.
C'est la seule industrie
qui marche aujourd'hui,
qui crée des emplois.
C'est le lieu par excellence
du business.
-Merci,
madame Aminata Traoré.
*Propos indistincts
Oui. Niagalé...
*-Je peux terminer ?
-Terminez, alors,
parce qu'on a peu de temps.
*-Non, je m'excuse.
Peut-être que mes arguments
ne plaisent pas,
mais je veux juste dire
que toutes ces guerres
sont les guerres
de la mondialisation prédatrice.
-Merci.
On vous a entendue.
Alors, Niagalé Bagayoko,
je voudrais quand même vous poser
cette question géostratégique.
Que l'Afrique veuille reprendre
son destin en main,
on le comprend.
Qu'elle veuille le faire
hors d'une présence
militaire française,
ça semble même aujourd'hui
un avis favorable
- vous avez entendu
le général Clément-Bollée -,
mais l'Afrique va aussi
vers d'autres pôles géostratégiques.
Des pays comme l'Afrique du Sud,
l'Ethiopie, ont rejoint les BRICS,
où il y a la Chine, la Russie,
des pays comme l'Iran
et d'autres pays
qui sont pas neutres
dans les conflits mondiaux
et qui même les attisent.
L'Iran est impliqué
dans le terrorisme islamiste.
La Russie est impliquée
dans le désastre ukrainien,
et on voit des pays africains
rentrer là-dedans.
Comment vous voyez
cette Afrique de demain
sans une présence française...
Emile Malet hésite.
...mais sous l'influence
d'autres continents ?
-Alors, plusieurs éléments.
L'Iran n'est absolument pas impliqué
dans le terrorisme en Afrique,
quelle que soit la façon
dont on prend l'équation.
On peut parler éventuellement
des puissances qui ne sont pas...
-L'Iran est impliqué
dans le terrorisme
à travers les Houthis...
-Il y en a d'autres.
-Le Hamas et le Hezbollah.
-Si on parle
de l'Afrique,
l'Arabie saoudite ou le Qatar
ont certainement
plus d'influence
sur l'islamisation...
-Des pays africains sont rentrés
dans le groupe des BRICS,
où l'Iran est rentré.
-Tout à fait, aussi.
C'était pour mentionner ce point-là.
Ce qui est très important,
c'est que pour moi,
ce qui se produit
d'historique,
comme le dit Antoine Glaser,
c'est cette volonté
des Etats africains de diversifier
leurs partenariats
et de maximiser
leurs intérêts.
A mon sens,
cela n'exclut absolument pas
la France, à terme.
Alors, aujourd'hui,
on est dans une période
de crispation intense,
mais je pense
que d'ici quelques années,
quatre ou cinq ans
tout au plus,
il y aura cohabitation
de différents partenaires.
Vous parlez de la Russie.
Il est très intéressant,
si on prend le cas de la Libye,
de voir que la Russie,
à travers Wagner, soulignons-le,
soutenait le même camp,
à savoir celui du maréchal Haftar,
que la France.
Donc, ce type de partenariats
très opportunistes
de la part des Etats africains,
qui renvoie, tout simplement,
à la realpolitik
de tout Etat dans le monde,
fait qu'à mon avis, des partenaires
de nature très différente
vont cohabiter
les uns à côté des autres
dans les coopérations
notamment militaires
qui vont se mettre en place
dans les années à venir
entre le continent africain
et différentes zones géographiques
de par le monde.
-Antoine Glaser,
vous partagez
cette vision géopacifique ?
-Pas géopacifique.
Niagalé, elle a jamais dit...
-"Géopolitique", on va dire.
-Je suis complètement d'accord
avec elle.
Les Africains,
ils prennent en compte
ce que nous,
on n'a pas pris en compte.
On a continué à croire
qu'on était chez nous
dans nos 13 anciennes colonies.
Les Africains prennent en compte
toutes les opportunités
qui s'offrent à eux.
Vous avez raison,
il y a une répartition
des tâches en Afrique
entre les Chinois,
qui font le business,
et les Russes, qui font aussi
une partie de la sécurité,
mais c'est de la faute
de la France,
qui s'est retirée
de Centrafrique,
qui a laissé arriver Wagner,
qui a abandonné le terrain.
Les Russes ont négocié
avec les rebelles centrafricains.
Vous avez raison de parler...
On a parlé beaucoup
de géopolitique,
mais vous avez raison
de parler de géoéconomie
parce que maintenant,
l'Afrique
va redevenir
totalement géostratégique
sur le plan
des matières premières.
Des pays comme la RDC
le sont déjà pour le tantale,
mais vous avez le lithium.
Je sais que les Américains,
en Centrafrique, regardent
des gisements de terres rares.
Donc, on est
dans une période historique.
Il faut que la France
prenne en compte
la mondialisation de l'Afrique.
C'est pour ça...
C'est une question historique.
Ce boomerang que se prend la France
sur le sentiment antifrançais...
Vous-même, vous dites :
"On n'y a plus d'intérêt
"et il y a
des sentiments antifrançais."
C'est cette espèce de retour
de l'impensé,
comme on dit.
-On va s'arrêter là.
Il y a beaucoup
de questions
qu'on pourrait poser.
On aurait pu continuer,
même on fera une prochaine émission
sur ce sujet-là.
Je voudrais vous remercier,
mais avant de vous remercier,
je voudrais vous citer
une brève bibliographie.
Aminata Traoré,
vous avez publié
"L'étau : l'Afrique
"dans un monde
sans frontières".
On a eu l'occasion d'en parler.
On a vraiment très peu de temps.
En deux mots,
qu'est-ce que vous vouliez dire
de cette Afrique
dans un monde sans frontières ?
Vraiment en deux mots,
on a très peu de temps.
*-Je voulais juste dire...
Aminata Traoré hésite.
Le monde est en train
de changer.
On nous a parlé de monde
sans frontières,
mais en réalité,
il n'y a que des murs.
-Bien, voilà,
une définition.
Antoine Glaser,
vous avez publié
parmi vos nombreux ouvrages
sur l'Afrique
"Arrogant comme un Français
"en Afrique".
Vous dénoncez cette arrogance...
-Moi, ce qui m'a surpris
en tant que journaliste
- je suis pas expert ni rien -,
c'est la manière dont la France
a exporté
sur tout un continent
toute sa science,
son savoir-faire, sa Constitution,
en dehors de sa langue,
et a contrôlé complètement
un certain nombre de pays
et n'a pas appris
de l'Afrique.
Je pense que là,
il faut changer de logiciel,
il faut s'intéresser
aux Africains.
Moi, ce qui m'avait intéressé,
c'est les systèmes
de parenté en Afrique.
Il faut inverser le logiciel.
-Merci.
Niagalé Bagayoko,
vous avez publié une étude
sur le multilatéralisme sécuritaire
de l'Afrique
à l'épreuve
de la crise sahélienne.
-Oui, parce qu'il n'y a pas
que la France
qui est rejetée
sur le continent africain,
il n'y a pas que les autres
partenaires internationaux,
comme les Nations Unies,
il y a aussi
une très forte remise en cause
des acteurs multilatéraux,
comme l'Union Africaine,
comme la CEDEAO,
comme la CEEAC,
qui ont, elles aussi, démontré
leur incapacité à faire face
à la crise sécuritaire actuelle.
Donc, la remise en cause est globale
et ne concerne pas
que la France aujourd'hui.
-Il me reste à vous remercier.
Merci, mesdames,
merci, messieurs,
d'avoir participé
à cette brillante conversation
et prospective
puisque des choses
ont été émises aujourd'hui.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP,
qui a permis la réalisation
de cette émission.
Avant de nous quitter,
je vous rappelle cette pensée
de Jean-Marie Bockel,
un ancien ministre français,
qui a été touché personnellement,
puisqu'il a perdu un fils
dans les combats en Afrique :
"Les coups d'Etat en Afrique
n'améliorent en rien la situation
"des pays concernés,
au contraire."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA